do dating apps make it easy to find love
no no makes it easy to find sex
no that's it
like no and who's responsible
for the influx the day of dating apps
the science let's go into the the data
the science proves it so research has
been done
um that the way the dating apps work it
is that 80 percent actually ninety
percent of the women are choosing the
top uh 10 to 20 percent of men on there
and it's usually based on looks height
and money you heard 10 to 20 I heard
five percent well they like to they like
to skew it I'm just going on what the
numbers say like if you if you look at
the research if we if we really get into
it we could probably say the five
percent that you're that's what I
believe I actually think it's lower than
that and so the women are just swiping
right swiping right swiping right the
majority of women I think the comparison
was
um uh two to a hundred in terms of
people who are in women's who swipe
right on a woman women men will swipe a
hundred and women will only swipe two so
it's like it is women own these dating
apps and a lot of dating apps with fake
women on there and some women who are on
there who look good they're actually
just selling uh their their old their of
you know I don't know if you can say the
word here I don't know if it hurts it
but like they're of or they're saying uh
go to my Instagram or go to my of or hit
me up on here or my cash app is here so
even the women who are swiping right
there's a lot of scamming and all of
these other things and a lot of men are
genuinely looking for love and again
from 18 to 30 the there is three times
the number of men who are virgins in
sexless versus women so women own these
dating apps and we're we're responsible
for the men that we're choosing we're
not giving average men a chance because
we're picking things on vanity and and
things that don't have lasting value
they dating apps are for people who want
to have sex as you said
um dating apps are not necessarily for
people who want to find love
um I would say that love is actually
harder to find in this day and age
anyway anywhere that you go whether it
be in the club whether it be at a bar
whether it be on dating consider
Instagram a dating app and would you say
the same thing for Instagram I wouldn't
I wouldn't I would I know that when I I
actually remember I actually know that
when I was single I was on Instagram and
someone dm'd me and within three hours I
was at their house oh wow so yeah I
think it's better for women who are
looking who are looking for better
quality because to me
Instagram what his is I'm not on dating
apps at all that has brought me because
people because I'm actually putting out
quality content on there so guys are
seeing my mind not just a picture of me
looking cute and just some caption that
I decided to write but they're hearing
their mind hearing the quality I'm able
to go and see what they're talking about
their friends who they actually are and
you can actually I think Instagram is a
better place to vet if you really want
to and I'm getting
hey I mean the quality is is is is is is
amazing if in my opinion as a woman
who's looking to be a wife yeah I want a
Instagram from a business perspective
the majority of women are not using it
from a business perspective
I want to hear from the average chick
not a girl that's got her butt all over
Instagram just like normal pictures
nothing crazy would you say that
Instagram is a good way to meet people
for women
I think the best way yeah no no the best
way to meet a person is out in the real
life we need to get out in front of
these ones and zeros
and get out into the real world and just
start to meet people here's the thing is
that from a dating app perspective it
removes being able to talk to women it
it it it it becomes completely vanity it
becomes completely how good your
photographer was it comes completely
your angles in this and that yo listen
at the end of the day women
if you want to meet good guys and guys
if you want to meet good girls you got
to do it in real life yes you know so
much of this digital ecosystem listen I
love technology at the end of the day I
utilize technology technology has
allowed me to quit my nine to five I
will forever utilize technology but I
gotta understand when does it benefit me
and then when does it not and I think
like a lot of younger people today don't
understand it because they only have
seen it with technology here I grew up
when internet was not even a thing like
I've seen life before internet and then
I see it after internet and at the end
of the day listen women gonna fall in
love with what they hear not necessarily
what they see so of course two women per
100 is going to swipe right to left of
course because the visual is not as
important Instagram I think is different
because let's just say all of us all of
us in here we've met through digital
we've threat through internet like I
would not know Pearl if it was not for
the internet I would not know you I
would not know Maggie I would not know
so Sarah Garvey but I'm saying there are
men that I have met that I'm able to
average men
you're not meeting average Men You're
meaning above average men yeah so let's
talk about not the outliers let's talk
about the majority for the majority of
people the majority of people dating
apps do not benefit real life in person
Instagram again
my dad is on
if you guys DM a girl on Instagram would
you be taking her seriously or is that
more for account because because I sorry
onset but I'm about to go back to what
MCO was saying is that
um most men most younger men are
socially awkward because myself maybe
Melanie maybe
yeah they don't have to talk to women
they but we grew up in a time before the
internet so we could we could socialize
with people you know and it wasn't a
thing we could talk face to face we
could start up conversations but
generally the men of today the reason
why I'm asking about you I'm asking
about you personally no I I wanted a
relationship but when you were single if
you dm'd a girl on Instagram was that
for casual or for serious it depends on
the mindset that I was in if I uh there
was a time when I was so you would do
both single yeah I would do both so you
would yeah Instagram could
hypothetically for you good good Avenue
yep okay same thing
yeah so um bye yes buy my specific
results now you know throughout my life
I had not been looking for a relation
it's been with business college since
I've been in like a whole cold-blooded
relationship where I was like okay
that's my girlfriend and she was like
that's my boyfriend so generally when I
hit up women on Instagram it is for
not relationship now but at the same
time no it don't mean that like into the
future if I was to do that in the future
it would just be vetted specifically
for not relationship but it to me at the
end of the day women need to understand
this if a guy is not ready he's not
ready yeah it's expensive if a guy is
not ready he is not ready so so during
my periods of not ready if I hit you up
what's up okay
let them know so Instagram it's either
or I'm just curious either or I would
say it depends
is also used more than just data you
know a dating app is just for
relationship sex it's about romantic
interactions Instagram it could be
business it can be like you're showing
your family your your parents
again I just really want to hear from
the three guys okay so if you go oh
sorry go ahead go ahead if you go over
the majority of what people use
Instagram for it is not a good place to
find love and stuff right there I asked
for you
but I remember making my first Instagram
when it come out and the first thing
that come to mind was I wonder how many
girls I can talk to now
straight away it was just a casual it
was nothing maybe because I was younger
I'm not too sure about how it would be
now if I was single maybe if I was
even now I think it'd only be casual for
me I don't think you could actually go
onto a dating app and try to find love
because even at the point now I was
speaking to my single friends now
and I've said you know how is your love
life going well you was out the other
night how did that go and we went oh I
went to speak to a girl how'd that go
and he went she freaked out what'd you
mean she freaked out she goes well
because I approached her it's almost got
to the point now where dating apps have
destroyed the interactions
women are now when a man approached them
who's this creep and then they freak out
they really do I think maybe I could be
wrong but I think men are more open to
trying to speak to her women in public
whereas I don't think women are anymore
who is more afraid of commitment in
modern dating men or women
women
they're afraid of getting hurt the
pattern of the pattern that we have
created for ourselves ultimately right
dealing with situationships things of
that sort
it one if you've been dealing with a
counterfeit so long how do you recognize
the real right and so we're afraid to
get ourselves emotionally involved and
become vulnerable and intimate with
someone because we don't know if it's
the real deal because we don't know and
we've never been taught how to identify
what the real is so we're afraid because
like they say when men are ready men are
ready period they're committing but now
you look out and there's nothing to
commit to
hmm do you think women really can't tell
the difference between a guy who's going
to settle down and a guy who won't agree
or yeah
in this day and age especially when a
lot of the guys tell the girls up front
like she said I'm just curious out of
the guys just really quick when you guys
were in whole phase of Life did you tell
the girls oh absolutely I was 100 honest
this is where I'm at in life but they
always try to change you would they get
mad later
are in the face I've never had a whole
face
but I agree I would I I struggle with
the term counterfeit because that
assumes that a man is presenting himself
as a husband candidate or relationship
ready I think oftentimes we see what we
want to see and we blow past what they
say and we end up hurting ourselves but
blaming it on the men
do you think that's true or false I
think that's true I was thinking in
terms of counterfeit relationships not
the men being in counterfeits right
they've dealt with so many
situationships and things like that they
don't know what a real relationship
looks like right so even when a guy they
have trust issues right wait so what do
you mean they don't know what a real
relationship looks like they've never
seen a real relationship
precisely issues daddy issues trust
issues and to Camille's Point all of her
friends right she's she'll have a real
conversation with them and then two
weeks later they're talking back to the
same guy why because you know what it's
about why do you keep availing yourself
to that process why do we keep going in
these circular motions because we're
comfortable it's comfort with being hurt
right it takes something it takes some
level of vulnerability trust healing to
make ourselves available for something
new and different and because we're
unfamiliar with what that new is going
to be sometimes we're too afraid to open
ourselves up to that to explore I think
we know we just don't want what we
really should have I I think we want to
force what we want on someone else when
if we're just supposed to be in a
regular relationship we have a hard time
accepting that I think that's more of of
what it is I just I disagree that it's
um well who do you want like Prince
Charming or something I think ever every
girl does I mean that's how we're
socialized but I think the problem is
like you all said we all grew up before
the internet we were able to look at Pop
Culture entertainment and say oh that's
a great show show and it ended there I
never in my wildest dreams expected that
I would be driving a luxury car in my
20s or having elaborate dates like that
was not the real world but somehow the
lines have been blurred because of
culture because of moms because of
whatever and now we think what we see
out there is what we're supposed to be
living over here and 100 I don't think
women modern women today want Prince
Charming who do they want they want
Superman
they want they want they want to take
Superman and make them Clark Kent
but they just don't want Clark Kent they
want to tame Superman they want to tame
the alpha they want the alpha to want
them and only them in a monogamous
relationship and they don't want Prince
Charming off of deck I go over my
channel time and time again
good guys nice guys
petalizing them being simps giving them
the world and then they get sh upon they
don't want Prince Charming they want
Superman to convert him into Clark Kent
and then how often does it happen
foreign Russell Wilson There You Go
Sierra's prayer meanwhile she's still up
in the Oscars half-assed naked that's
right the nerve of you Sierra grow up
you're a mother times two can I first
say Savannah James look like we should
be talking about Savannah James way more
than Seattle Savannah James was the
standard on that Oscar's red carpet she
owned it it was hers she looked like a
bride all over again and I'm so proud of
her and I love her and I think she is
every woman needs to be following her
because she she's the epitome of
femininity and a wife and just being
quiet and but but but just she was
powerful it just seeing her I showed my
daughters her and I just said when I
compared her to all the other women that
was on the red carpet and my daughters
are just like they themselves I said
what do you think they said Savannah
James just looks like
I mean like a queen like like just like
they they were just like is she getting
married again like like are they
renewing their vows because she just
excellence and even how she conducts her
family she is we need to stop talking
about the negativity I think so much and
focus on the women who are doing it
right because I don't think they get
enough of their flowers and women like
that who are really doing what they
should do but shout out to Savannah
James I just have to say if you guys
haven't seen her she just looks go to
her Instagram follow her if you can for
those that don't know Savannah James
LeBron James's wife she so she came up
to the Oscars with a crazy looking yeah
no crumbs no crumbs in contrast to
Russell Wilson's wife Sierra so here's
the thing and I got to do a better job
of this on my channel as well as to
continue to promote the Savannah James
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible